des moines bouddhistes ont trouvé un
débouché plutôt originale pour les
vieilles bouteilles de plastique
les robes de ces moines thaïlandais ont
l'air tout ce qu'il y a plus normal
pourtant elles sont fabriquées à partir
de plastique recyclé des bouteilles sont
d'abord récupéré dans les villages
environnants puis déchiqueté en petits
blocs ont transformé en film
ce fils et ensuite un qui sait avec de
la fibre de coton puis le tissu est
coupée et cousu pour confectionner la
crise qui caractérise t les moines ont
recyclé environ 40 tonnes de plastique
en deux ans et ce n'est pas fini puisque
de plus en plus temple souhaite acheter
leurs robes
[Musique]